livre à l'antenne donc noël mamère aime
beaucoup la poésie est particulièrement
jacques prévert il a choisi soleil de
nuit publié par gallimard est réservé et
même une surprise aux amateurs de
prévert écoutons noël mamère un homme
avait un chien un chien qui l'appelaient
amour l'homme lui donnait à manger le
chien le lait chez l'homme caressait le
chien il le laissait aussi quand il
était seul parfois même il aboyait un
peu pour lui faire plaisir à gros chien
c'est mon chien c'est mon amour disait
l'homme c'est mon homme aboyer l'amour
mais un jour triste triste triste jour
l'homme s'est aperçu de certaines choses
ouf quand ce que je mangeais meilleur je
lui donne moins à manger
or s'il s'en aperçoit il se soit bras et
moi je resterai la seule sans mon chien
mon amour mon amour à moi de le tuer et
puis je ne mangerai rien ne sera perdu
et il le tue et ils le mangent mais à la
fin du repas faisant le beau et sortants
de dessous la table apparaît le fantôme
du chien machinalement l'homme jette à
l'ombre un os un os mais le fantôme du
chiendent son suaire se trouve très bien
et n'a pas faim il n'a pas faim dos
il regarde l'homme d'un bon oeil se
jettent dessus et le mange
puis il sort de la salle à manger on se
dit tout en se dandinant amour tout à
fait vivant il reprend ses couleurs et
son comportement
puis ils courent amour ils courent amour
dans la ville à la recherche d'un autre
maître amour pour faire le beau
amour pour se faire caresser amour pour
se faire battre
amour pour se faire tuer amour pour
dévorer dévorer dévorer
et bien ce texte ils s'appellent les
enfant de bohème voyez que le titre n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'ils racontaient
par jacques prévert et ce texte il
appartient un recueil qui vient d'être
édité par les éditions gallimard qui
s'appelle soleil de nuit ce sont les
textes écrits par jacques prévert entre
1935 et 1977
je souhaite que ce petit exercice de
style auquel je viens de me livrer vous
est donné le goût de vous replonger
lampre faire